what is going on YouTube you guys have
been asking a lot of questions again so
I'm gonna take the time to go ahead and
answer them I can't go ahead and name my
specific people because these questions
have been asked by a lot of people so
I'm gonna just go ahead and go through
them question number one David how tall
are you I am 6 foot / 6 foot 1 roughly
around there yes I'm a tall Asian and
that's not the only thing that's big on
me ladies you don't know sir my hands
question number 2 David are you single
apparently there's been some confusion
because in vlog number two there was a
girl named Phoebe that I said was my boo
boo such more sugar mama that is not
true it was a little joke that got out
of hand and everybody thought that she
and I weren't married we're not married
and apparently she wants me to go ahead
and say this out to you guys because
I've been cock-blocking her have she not
been together before no have I tried yes
and she denied me multiple times
specifically one story we went to LA
together for a trip and she was with me
when I was doing all my business there a
girl came up which was a fan and she
straight up went up to her and asked her
hey aren't you Davis's wife and this is
what she said no no God no no no no no
no you know that many times girl you had
to say no that mean time most common
question number three David do you date
the sisters and my tractor's sisters yes
I am I have I have a bit with one no
specifically for a reason because you
guys happen to be physically stronger
than me and I can't be play fighting
with my girlfriend and then lose oh damn
what's wrong with you man plain too
rough Melissa tinder here's the last
common question David do you sing yes I
sing before I started doing comedy I
actually was a musician and I was an R&B
singer too so I personally couldn't put
up a video that says you want my body
and at the bottom it says no thank you
you guys want to hear me sing here it
goes there's the sick not playing with
you
I want you from us hey hey I don't wanna
have to show you is nobody else but yes
go ahead keep on putting comments about
your ideas your thoughts and the stuff
that you want me to do stuff about
because all of this is my comedy but
it's also for you because you guys
support me and I want to thank you
that I don't want to get emotional [ __ ]
but I anyways those are the questions of
the day
remember leave some comments show some
love subscribe do whatever you want I
don't want to tell you to subscribe but
subscribe your boy over here loves you
very much
[ __ ] tits all the way peace out titties
nipples areola I don't know what am I
saying I don't know how to end this huh
for peace out I'm gonna call this
interesting comment of the day cold on
sale you David you fat son of a home
make some more video son
I like your sketches but at least
through the vlogs for the people who
love you and if not them than me I don't
love you I just
mu PS you better leave this my heart and
soul into it um sometimes you guys say
things that I don't know if it's a
compliment or an insult how you don't
call me a ho no sweet L you can't help
myself how does it feel to know that I
love you baby